みなさん、ここの
高低アクセントです。これは、この単語の高低アクセントの発音に関する2分間の簡単なチュートリアルなので
、多くの日本人学習者は、高低アクセント
が
複数の意味を持っている
ことを知っています。
彼は日本人で、別の人は他の人の
ように見えると聞きました。彼は非常に日本人のようであるか、彼の
マナーは非常に日本人であるため、ほとんどの
人
はよく知りません。 また
、さまざまな高低アクセントパターンを持っているので
、彼が日本人だと聞いた場合
、私
は通常の高低アクセントパターンを保持し、高低アクセントを維持したまま、私と一緒に日本高低アクセント
と言います。
とても日本人彼の仕事彼の
マナーはとても日本人です
ここでの基本的なルールは、
私が何かを聞いたと言いたい場合は、あなたが
知っていることであり
、ダシではなく、高低アクセントの文法パターンを使用
したいということです。
偉
そうな
ことを言いたいのなら何か他のことのように思える彼がとても日本人のようだと言いたいのなら彼は
とても日本人のようだ
だからもう一度
、彼はホームジーンダシで日本人だと聞いた。
彼はジェットのようにとても日本人だ。彼のマナーはとてもジェフだ。
彼のマナーはとても日本人である。
遺伝子の高低アクセントなので
、みんなに知らせたかったので、
これがお役に立てば幸いです。またすぐに話をします。